the jurogan experience didn't john jones
block you
i don't think he likes me
what did you uh
what did you do well i guess it's just
i've made a few videos just dissecting
his case and giving my opinion on what i
think he did
and
i don't he just doesn't like it
obviously because it's just bringing up
[ __ ] that is in his past that he doesn't
want dug up i guess this is the stuff
about the drug testing yeah because
there was that whole debacle with the uh
you know the pulsing and the tyrannoball
metabolite yeah
what's your take on that
um personally i think that if you go
back historically to the beginning like
obviously the guy is pretty loose on
what he's willing to do in terms of you
know substances yeah so
with him
um if you go back to his first positive
test results i believe he tested
positive for clomiphene and letrozole
way back in like 2016 or something so if
you look at those two drugs one of them
is an aromatase inhibitor that you would
use to prevent gynoformation usually
and then clomid is like a fertility drug
you would use to restore testosterone
production
or in women use it to aid in fertility
so using those two drugs back then
to me seemed like something you would be
doing to either you know prevent the
gyno from what you were using at a time
when it was less scrutinous perhaps
and then the clomid you know to recover
or something was tainted as what his
claim was but we already have you know
history of him doing this or getting
popped for something pretty stupid to
get popped for way back in you know
2015-2016
era approximately
after that he test positive for tyrion
ball
and then thereafter the pulsing but the
thing that's interesting about that is
when nowitzki talks about this pulsing
m3 metabolite he refers to well it's not
him he's just reiterating the research
and it's
ultimately they use this reference point
of clomid pulsing as a
kind of a proxy to exemplify
look here's a drug that stores itself in
fat tissue and pulses over time so they
use clomid as an example of a because
they can't just give a a human a [ __ ]
ton of tyranidable and like trying to
figure out if this is going to work or
not so they give them this fertility
drug or they've looked in the data and
found to parse out this information
about clomid pulsing and they use that
as a reference point for like look
there's a drug that can pulse over time
but the interesting thing is jon jones
literally popped for clomid before but
he's never had that pulse so he has this
tyrion ball that keeps paul saying but
the clomid they use as the reference
point of a drug that can pulse
never pulsed for him but didn't he say
that the clomid was from tainted food
yeah but he still got it in a system so
it's like if you ingested clement why is
that not pulsing so what causes
something to pulse
explain pulsing to people that don't
know what we're talking about like the
idea would be that metabolites of these
hormones like first of all with
tyrannoball
after icarus came out and like shortly
around that the rod chankov is the one
who came up with the m3 metabolite test
and like extended the detection window
of tariniball and that's actually when i
mentioned the summer olympics and how
many people retroactively got
their metal stripped or they got popped
for the summer olympics for
like 12 years in totality a lot of those
positive test results for were forward
to ruinable after they used rod
chankov's data to like retroactively
test the urine samples and see
they thought at the time it was
undetectable because they got out of
their system based on the current
detection windows but then when rod
shankoff came out with his he came out
with his data
and when they went back and tested it
using his assay you could figure out
oh past that date they actually detected
for that you know the longer term
metabolites
so
the the idea between behind the pulsing
is these metabolites that linger they
can store themselves in like fat tissue
essentially and they can like liberate
themselves
over time sporadically has that been
proven or is that theoretical yeah and
it was proven in clomid data which is
interesting because jon jones literally
has plot for clomid but didn't pulse for
that yeah
but it hasn't been proven before with
this stuff no it's a runable never so
what's your take on that like i think
personally
um like the amount of turin ball he had
was so small
a lot of times like for certain
compounds like tarinibal the only way
you're gonna get it is like underground
like you're gonna get it it's not a
pharmaceutical product that's designed
for like a clinical application so
you're going to get it designed by
an underground lab who sells steroids to
you know random bodybuilders or a
chemist in you know china or something
and you're kind of just banking on the
fact that it's not going to be tainted
they're going to use like clean
equipment it's going to be whatever drug
you're hoping to get
and there are a lot of different
scenarios that might you know explain it
and there's different theories like i
could have that could hypothetically
either one could be true potentially but
i think one of the options is a drug he
thought he was getting that was
potentially undetectable was tainted
with tyrannoball
or he thought he could get around the
detection window by taking it unaware of
rod chance of long-term data that came
out
or
there's like a variety of different
things that could be happening but
ultimately for him he got in his system
and
on paper when you look at his
testosterone levels and his ratios of
testosterone and epi testosterone like
when he fought dc
they were so out of whack that it would
not be explainable in my opinion by
anything other than some sort of
suppression of your system via the usage
of something so to me not not hard
training because hard training does
suppress it right yeah but to the degree
where he's literally like a female
probably not so he's really it was that
bad yeah so normally
the levels would be over
10 times what he had
in general i'd have to pull it up to
remember exactly but he was like in the
single digits for urinary testosterone
which otherwise should be like it was
like 60 60 plus or something he was like
four or something
and it was multiple data points of his
testosterone being single digits to a
point that would indicate significant
suppression in my opinion
what what could be another possible
explanation for it other than
significant suppression of the super low
test levels um
i don't know
castration is that bad uh yeah it was
pretty [ __ ] bad dude it was like the
equivalent of you only have your adrenal
glands producing testosterone basically
like your balls are essentially
non-functional but explain this then if
that's the case then
how would he perform well because of his
if he's going into a fight with his
testosterone that low because if you
have a drug that's suppressing your
system
the drug you're taking presumably is
what is driving your performance vectors
that you deem useful enough to use in
competition so hypothetically if i was
using turinabol
like all those athletes in russia or
whatever using tarinible you're gonna
have some suppression of your
testosterone levels which you know on
paper could inhibit performance but
you're using the drug to drive
performance okay so even though your
endogenous levels are lower
you're relying on this compound you're
using that you deem useful enough
to dope with potentially so
here's my question if they're using a
test that's sophisticated enough to
detect that he has these very low
testosterone levels and he has this
pulsing of tyriniball
like where is the room for this compound
that's going to significantly increase
his performance
yeah so let's just say hypothetically
tyrional or any random oral steroid is
not like presumably this isn't 100
factual that's just speculating based on
the levels and whatnot but if he has a
certain even if he has crushed test
the room if they're not looking for a
certain drug that's not on their list
and you're using it full board whatever
dose you want because they can't detect
it because they don't even know it
exists
then that's going to be significantly
performance enhancing okay so then we're
talking about something like the balco
clear that kind of a deal potentially
so it see the thing is like when they
catch someone with something like what
uh victor conte had
come clean with that they used for barry
bonds and all these different athletes
undetectable you rub it on your skin and
no one knew what it was
we think oh well they caught that guy
they're more sophisticated now you can't
get away with that now do you think it's
possible there could be some new
designer steroids or some new compound
that's not on the list of things to be
tested for because we don't even know it
exists but yet it is significantly
enhancing performance
uh yes like the clear if you don't have
an assay developed for it
detecting it is
essential you can't prove anything
exists in the body if you don't have an
acid to detect it so even though you
have this elaborate list of steroids
that are known about
if you have a novel drug and you don't
know
to detect it even if you have other
markers that look [ __ ] up like it's
testosterone levels in the gutter
there's no threshold amount where you
pop because your test is in the gutter
they look for high test they don't look
for low so if you're really low randomly
they might be like oh that's weird and
keep an eye on it maybe further test you
further for other stuff
but it's doesn't mean you couldn't be
using something gung-ho the entire time
so i do think designer drugs exist i
don't necessarily know that they're
being leveraged highly in the designer
steroid family because you could
hypothetically
probably be able to determine this
compound derived from testosterone was
manipulated and you know see something
iffy and you know dig into it and get a
perhaps find out pretty clear
pretty soon what it is and retroactively
you know penalize that guy but i do
think there are novel agents being
developed from the growth hormone side
of things epo side of things
um the testosterone obviously there's
the carbon isotope ratio proof
cholesterol
testosterone which you could also
potentially argue the guy was using
basic like trt and came off and like
crashed his system you know at the time
of the test or something like there's a
million different reasons but ultimately
seeing that level in his urine
testing for a random compound having in
the past test deposit for a fertility
drug and an aromatase inhibitor you
would only use in the context of
like
drug use essentially intentionally in
most cases
it's just like highly improbable i don't
think that he's at least tried to do
some [ __ ] to get around the system
you